I see him like hit it and he looks
and I go there
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right everybody welcome back to
another amazing episode of the careful
boys and today Steve has new shoes
those are pretty boiling
still pretty sick those kind of shoes
can show the tongue yeah the tongue has
the big fat W on it and then did you
design that I did how much did that cost
it cost me six thousand dollars
6250 yeah no it cost like 50 bucks they
but also I'm looking across from me and
I see that Joe's wearing Crocs dude it's
not even mine it's Bart wow wow Mine
yeah you used it for that thing we
filmed is that a custom color and it was
in it was back there so I decided to
keep it what do you think about the Croc
it's a pretty good shoe it was my it's
my first time it's pretty comfy right
yeah it's an all-terrain shoe but I
realize you like if I wear if I wear it
without socks it cuts my foot no wonder
everyone always wears socks with it it
cuts your eyes it doesn't come my foot
it's like think you have like pussy-ass
feet do you have bootleg Crocs yeah dude
I don't know because what I don't like
socks with it is because it's rubber
I've noticed it puts holes in my socks
so it cuts your sauce but it doesn't cut
your iron skin that's it dude that's too
much logic show your couch that doesn't
make sense oh yeah duh yeah like it'll
straight up like start putting whole
like this probably yeah look it's just
me [__] like this because I'm just
[__] up a hole at the bottom what are
you doing in those Crocs good thing you
have socks on Jesus I think Joe's right
what's with your shirt though my shirt
where'd you get that oh that's one I got
from B team it's pretty cool because
keep Jiu Jitsu gay
or else what
or else dude that's incredible on more
serious topics bar has been training and
preparing for his power lifting meat for
months now yeah like that bar era is
gone that's our favorite bar and he went
into [__] skinny hot ripping correct
it's not gone bring back fat bar we like
fat Bart that's all I'm saying but how
was your power lifting me it was okay
do you feel disappointed with your
results yeah is it the one that taika
went because you were like I gotta show
my son that I still come here and then
he's like Daddy loses too
[Laughter]
no but uh I uh I had certain goals that
I wanted for myself so I wanted to get
it but I did it and I think it's just I
was trying to do too much like for this
meet I was trying to get like lean and
also put up weight and then when you're
trying to get strength it's hard to do
both so like I hit certain numbers in
training already that's almost like if
you're like let's say you're training
for a marathon and you already hit like
let's say a sub four marathon and you're
like okay cool then on the actual day I
should be able to hit a sub for a
marathon uh but because of the weight
cut
the day of training uh or day of the
meet I wasn't able to hit even some of
the training I'm sure you cut yeah yeah
right before no no I've been just having
a graphic for four months but you just
start getting like weaker and weaker and
weaker and weaker and I was like oh [__]
so so from the point that you actually
hit those numbers during training you
lost even more weight yeah oh why were
you trying to lose weight before the the
lift well it's just my overall goal for
this year like I want to like because
I'm technically in Fitness you know but
I always [__] around like I'm using he's
in Fitness my favorite kind of Fitness
I [__] around all the time so I was like
you know I really wanted this dick in
his mouth hey what makes more money JK
or barbell you're in Fitness bro you're
in [__] fit right now is is JK I mean
barbell yeah whoops good thing you
didn't say that
let's edit that one
yeah so I was like this I want to really
take Fitness seriously so I want to get
lean I want to get strong and usually
those are kind of two separate things
but like so for example in training I
hit 500 a couple times on Squat and so
which means like 450 should be pretty
easy 4-40 should be pretty easy but then
the day of the meet I get under the bar
and under warm-ups under 400 I was like
uh oh it was like that have you ever
felt that before in different Meats
sometimes or is it warm up you're like
oh [__] a hundred pounds different oh
yeah I mean you'll you'll feel like if
you're really in tune with your body and
you've been training like you'll feel a
bounce like oh [__] my muscles be poppy
today you know like you just [__]
ready to go yeah and then some days
you're like you go down with like a
deflated Tire like uh [__] and it's
steroids
you so troubleshooting that what do you
feel like the the issue of yo it's a hot
fix for that yeah what's a hot fit why
do you think you were saying so the
hotfix So Silent Mike was there he was
my Handler which is like 8K like a like
a coach so that's good so usually how
proud of the theme it works is for every
single live Squad bench deadlift you
have three attempts so you kind of work
up to and you want to like kind of
alley-oop yourself to your third final
Max so like let's see if I'm aiming for
500 I'll probably go 425 for first
attempt for a fit or no 450 475 500. got
it the mid house in the warm-up room and
he sees that because I've been sending
him my videos for the last two weeks too
he goes oh [__] you don't look as poppy
as usual like he starts bumping the
numbers down so it's kind of like like
NASCAR you know oh this guy's not taking
those turns as good let's get the tires
out of less grippy because you can't
handle these tires you kind of have to
make like on the yeah make on the Fly
adjustments so he was there so he helped
me still have a good meet
um so I hit PR's which is like personal
record which is like at my weight it's
pretty cool I was Stronger Than I was
before but it wasn't the number that I
wanted to hit so it made it sound like
you failed miserable yeah this is the
most like what the [__] is this you
can't give yourself a dub yeah you can
hit PR's that's a big W because it's bad
Asian boy I texted him and I was like
110 dude if I could squat 500 yeah you
know how obnoxious I am I would walk
around telling everybody I [__] Squad
500. you're not being obnoxious you
don't tell everybody something no I
don't know
it's squat 500. every context in every
situation get merch made already 500
Club yeah and then on the back and say
what do you Squad question mark
did Sir yeah but just seriously just
asking how much you squat that's what
you would so yeah but the coolest part I
really wanted tiger to come because he
did come to one of my earlier meets when
he was two but he was [__] too
[__] like like Jill's holding taika
like on the left beautiful and the tank
was like
and I'm like I'm over here I'm over here
look at me and he's just like well
imagine what it was like when he's at
Disneyland at six months old
that's what I was trying to tell you
back then but we went for us I think I
know I said that too but now it's cool
you can hear I could hear his like
little high trouble voice
you can hear me yelling for you yeah
like a little baby he'll just be like
what do you think was smarter tiger or a
hamster
uh two yeah I think a hamster hamster
yeah yeah
so at least that's like a hamster you
give it food it goes oh food taika just
give him like [__] food and he's like
that's not pizza
[Laughter]
but you're also like not gonna be here
in your audition JK again tomorrow
because you're going to another Palace
yeah that one I was competing at this
one I'm uh like they're making
appearance at
[Laughter]
it the man that didn't hit his numbers
but he's special anyway somehow you
watched him not squat 500. here's Quan
[Laughter]
wait do they have lockout songs for
powerlifting needs they used to for
appearances so they they used to um
where there wasn't that many lifters so
people could choose and cue it now and
there was more time yeah but now if it's
a smaller meet maybe your third attempt
they'll play it because it gets hyped
people like because they feel oh yeah
they feel what you're vibing from and
then Everyone likes it they're right our
lifting needs take a long time they're
like nine hours what the [__] that's why
I texted you after
floor seats
ASAP this is my 20. ASAP bird wow he's
that fur guy pause it go to the later
part and then play it again we're gonna
get you monetized this is like a
beginning dude I just I just want to
lift the song
Ah that's pretty gangster dude I like
that the funny thing is they play this
for my third attempt and I didn't get my
lips I was like coming out hype like
oh [__]
do you feel like more or less hype
though but you were hype oh he was
shaking dude it'd be like WWE they play
your song and then you [__] just trip
over the Rope yeah that's like Dude
remember that guy who came out like the
guy came out we were watching something
and this guy comes out like a [__]
samurai costume or some [__] and he goes
and like gets knocked out in three
seconds
yeah it was like that that's the
sacrifice I know it's funny because the
meat director like he was like uh almost
like doing me a favor like she's like
oh [__] you guys are doing that he goes
yeah I'm like floor seats ASAP Ferg he
goes I got you three goals and I see him
like hit it and he looks
and I go there
[Laughter]
should have had a donut yesterday I know
the day before probably all right I
think that's something that I'm not used
to so before a lot of the power looking
Meats I did was uh 24-hour weigh-ins so
I'm used to like gaining 10 pounds in 24
hours I feel like a monster the next day
oh God this Federation at same day when
so that's why you you win and you're
lifting in two hours so I'm not used to
like I was trying to rehydrate and like
carb up sodium up were you competing at
a lower weight class I was yeah I was
cutting I mean in covet I was like 220
so I cut all the way down to 181. can
ask what do you get if you win trophy
he's where he's wearing it yeah
that's what I was afraid wait did you
did you win for your weight class
I don't even know because we were there
for uh uh to shoot a series so once our
like series was completed we didn't want
to wait till the afternoon for the
afternoon lifters to lift so we saw
crispy pork gang so we all just left to
go eat time oh that's nice
books oh it does it's not like the Thai
Town one no that's what because you
brought me to that one in Hollywood and
then so I suddenly rolled up in the
morning I was like dude afterwards we
gotta eat here Bart doesn't care about
his numbers but he does care about his
numbers and then he's like I don't care
if I won he doesn't even know his
results I actually don't I actually
don't even know he was there for work
though come on he did this to bring
tiger with him so the Tiger has a memory
of his dad losing itself
but he still continues on keep trucking
along so you can make a Instagram post
like guys you need to send your kids to
watch you lose yeah good development so
you went in there like full camera team
influencer style didn't even finish the
meet I did finish the meat I finished
the meat but we didn't stay until the
meat finished so selfish there's so many
people there that's
[Laughter]
like the producers are like they're kind
of like writing the story on the spot so
I think had we not had our ending we
would have probably stayed to see what
the ending was but out of nowhere I got
a randomly piss tested so we were like
oh this is the book ending right here
because like like after all it's done I
went to the back and the ref comes and
he goes I need you to pee in a cup and
then you're like you think I
can we do a video where you come up to
me and you go hey I have to piss test
you and I just run away and then they're
like yeah and I was like oh [__] so they
let me so if you watch the video oh
that's cool you see my dick on camera
it's pixelated by pee in a cup I did all
the whole process and we're like there's
no that ending it would just be it would
feel like attack on if we showed the
other part of the rest of the meat you
know so I was like okay that's the
bookmark ending we're good yeah and then
[__] the rest of me so we had the story
complete already and you're like hey can
you arrest me
can I spend nine months in prison while
we film it there's a steroid tester have
to see your dick come out like he has to
stand there he goes I have to see your D
like to hold it yeah then some have like
a bag and they're squeezing in there you
know they want to see your dick peeing
into the cup and then you like have to
tape it and sign and that's fair but I
get to call him a dick washer the whole
time like you like this don't you yeah
you like this huh you like watching my
dick
how do they prove it's not like a
prosthetic dick connected to some I
gotta hold it he's got it did he do this
yeah dick check there's a guy who just
dresses up like a ref goes around like
yeah you need to pee in there there's
some like weird scammer guy that's like
honestly he could have he could have
just put on a polo shirt that said like
official Geyers he's got a [__]
whistle this is a regulation a whistle I
need you to pee in the cup or I'll blow
the whistle sir that's why he randomly
drug checked Bart out of everyone yeah
just bark he's like um I'm gonna see his
day did that make you feel a little
flattered you're like it you know I did
look pretty strong out there I would be
on steroids so usually what they do is
if you Podium like three two or one yeah
did they check one of those guys yeah
but I've also been at Meats did you
Podium well I don't know I left oh yeah
that's right so um
but it's like it's kind of like like
you're like in the Olympics like there's
20 swimmers right and there's only like
10 lanes so they do this 10 first then
that 10 yeah and then the best and then
another so it's like that so I'm a
morning session then they have afternoon
session and then after that uh they kind
of tally it all up yeah but then the
story was really good that they pissed
us to me randomly so we just cut it
right there but no party you checked
afterwards like go on a website and be
like I wonder how I did let me see yeah
let's do it do you think that you taught
Tega a really good lesson of like
showing up to something and then leading
before the results happen
not giving it any respect and pulling
out your dick in front of somebody
[__] who cares about every all the
other competitors you know not giving it
any respect at all just leaving I think
if he's older because he's still
semi-retarded if he's older I would play
it differently I think right now I just
want to show them like so he's like
regular hamster right now yeah right now
I'm relating it to jiu jitsu me you know
like just if you give it your all that's
good keep Jiu Jitsu gay yes and then
later on I'm like you might want to try
to win something well that's cool so at
18 minutes do we all just walk out I
know yeah
I'm in right where Bart's like oh I got
the results all this balance yeah all
right let me see dude we'll [__] about
his score this guy doesn't even know how
to find it here's another website it's
new technology dude didn't they didn't
used to do that before subjective would
you rather find out your scores show up
to JK tomorrow I think
that's the would you rather I think the
score is to see if you're the strongest
in the world right or if you for that me
for that all yeah for that no in the
world because PR means if you beat your
previous record because your personal
record their State records National
records International records so aren't
we all trying to beat ourselves
[Music]
quit surfing the net I haven't competed
I haven't competed in like maybe five
years here's an idea quit halfway so
they got yeah yeah yeah
they got crazy ass absolutely he hasn't
completed in five years and he still
gets invited to the powerlifting memes
he's got to make an appearance
appearance that's pretty cool that they
asked you to make an appearance do you
do that often for powerlifting yeah I
would say so that's pretty cool that's
really cool I mean it's like you go in
the [__] culture don't bring me into
your [__] halfway quitting don't your
Bible survive culture Vibe I think I
think I think quartz onto something this
is an interesting change Anthony come to
shock culture
it's not like shock collar yeah like you
know how they go invite you it's like
stuff like that
come show your face even though
everyone's stronger than you now I'm
like sure
look how much
it's your day do the kids these days are
[__] incredible say Hey you helped
start this thing but everybody's ending
it for you better than you oh dude okay
okay this is good all right are you
looking at memes no okay one two three
four five
laughs
one two three four I got fifth place
out of how many people out of six you
know what they say if you're not first
you're out of five people out of if it's
out of 30 that's not bad out of one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
ten let me see I have to look see they
don't got these things organized very
well they're still working it's them
it's them that's the problem it's not me
look at the website kind of all over the
place tonight 10 11 12 13 14 like 15 or
16. that's pretty hey that's really good
dude top pork
people that like like have passion for
this and you have left that's great
well kind of true though Clark didn't
give a [__] about this man and he got
fifth he got he got his storybook ending
and he's like I'm out I tried my best
for like four you guys saw me I was
[__] wasn't eating any of the yummy
stuff you got a storybook any and he got
a ref to act yeah you got a Craigslist
actor because he's like he's like hey
wouldn't it be like because you this is
kind of a loophole you've found because
it's like hey like take your dick out
let's be right now you're like hey can I
real quick can I like fake run out of
here and then you could fake around
there grab a bag of piss or some [__] do
some kind of weird thing go vomit in the
alley or some [__] no they wanted me
they wanted to see my dick after dude on
camera that's pretty cool I feel like
they chose Bart though because they knew
this guy wasn't on steroids so they
choose all the guys that aren't because
then they could be like look we had a
clean [__] certified group oh
I think a lot of people think you're on
steroids yeah no I looked it up they
don't think
before this over show us your new tattoo
oh
God cool tasks yeah it says boom
shakalaka DD which is taika's favorite
he still says it you think when he's
like 25 though he's gonna be like why
the [__] did you do that Dad it's
embarrassing he's like you know I hate
that I hate that sentence and then he
has a his goggles is when you jump into
the pool why'd you give him blackface I
hate this I hate you Dad
dude that's a really good task yeah
hey does does it does it hurt like crazy
the closer you get to your armpit if
everyone tells me like this area by the
armpit is [__] crazy
just this whole area hurts oh yeah under
your it's like so sensitive oh how many
hours
oh dude it was like 14. pics what'd you
do the whole time you did it in one city
yeah I just laid there like this and
then and then your hand was going numb
like this
[Laughter]
you even put the meat halfway
how'd you block out that much time for
yourself
you don't [__] up that much time to
sleep
it's so funny it's true we've all we've
known it forever this [__] guy you
can't get that much time with him he's
like I gotta go to a [__] thing I
gotta know can't even imagine you going
like this
it's doing nothing I was actually uh
so this guy you have to book three
months out and I've already rescheduled
three times he was like I Tattoo You No
More [__] so I was like so this is
that's like when this came up as I just
got to do it because it's I was supposed
to get this tattoo in 2022. oh but I
rescheduled every single time and I was
like where is he at what city um Vegas
oh wow I don't know much about tattoos
but that takes 14 hours yeah I could do
that yeah well most people do it most
people do it in sessions most people
they'll come back after a couple you
know
they'd get it over a month get it done
over a month it's like impact font and
some shading yeah they're like you could
you could do 12.
what are you paying by the hour
[Music]